[Music]  the time has come to crown our queen  after weeks of fierce Lisa Shan RuPaul's  Drag Race named its season ten winner on  Thursdays finale America's next drag  superstar is aquaria  sometimes in life you're not always  given a second chance but if you do take  advantage of it and go out with a bang  we have worked obviously so hard to  finally be here after waiting for so  long  it's very validating and it's it's just  I could not be more excited  [Music]  aquarias win wasn't the only buzz worthy  moment of the night fans were stunned  when Asia O'Hara integrated live  butterflies into her routine  sadly they fail to take flight  Asia profusely apologized for the mishap  on Twitter her lengthy statement read in  part quote it's important that everyone  knows that I would never purposely hurt  any living being and have the utmost  respect for all animals  RuPaul also took us down memory lane  celebrating the show's 10 season  milestone  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]